One of the biggest mind blowing moments
I think of my limited comprehension of
what it means to be a living being was
when I found out that carbon and all the
stuff that makes us has to come
out of a dying star, like the,
that alone,
that there's this very strange cycle of
these enormous fireballs that forge the
material that makes Brian
Cox. Yeah. Like what?
That,
that one alone that there
is some strange loop of,
of,
of biological life that comes from stars,
which is like no most elemental
thing that we can observe.
We see these things in the skin,
we see the sun in the sky.
It's this all powerful ball of fire and
that that is where the building blocks
for a person come from. And I said,
and they will be from the carbon.
That's him tonight,
buddy. That you're right.
They all got made in stars because they
would, does none of it at the big bang.
There's only hydrogen and helium, tiny
bit of lithium to be precise, but no,
nothing else.
And so it was all made in styles and
he's probably from different styles.
You know, the, the seems in your buddy,
they're not all from one style
that cooks it and then died.
There'll be a mixture of stuff
for many styles in your body now.
And I agree with you. The, the, what
more do you want? You know, when I,
when I see people, the guy I want, I want
more than that. I wasn't, but you know,
there must be more to it. What do you
mean the, the, the, we have, we have,
we were the ingredients now buddy to
assembled in the house of long dead stars
over billions of years and the assembled
themselves spontaneously and to
temporary structures that can think
and feel and explore and then there's
structures will decay
away again at some point.
And in the very far future there'll be
no structures left. So, so there we are,
we exist in this little window when we
can observe this magnificent universe.
Why do you want any more?
I think to people, well,
I think a lot of people aren't aware
of all the, all the information, right?
And then I think on top of it,
for some people it's just,
it's so overwhelming the this,
this concept of 13.8 billion years of
everything to get to this point that we're
at right now,
it's so overwhelming that they want to
simplify it and want to put it into some
sort of a fable structure.
Something where it's something that's
very common and similar and familiar.
Yeah. I, I agree and, and,
but I think that's the,
the, is the, the, the
journey that we go on,
the real treasure,
I think is in that journey of
trying to face the incomprehensible.
It's,
it's in that realization that it's almost,
it's almost impossible to believe that we
exist. Right? Yeah, that's right. That's,
that's, that's a wonderful thing. Yeah.
And I think that that's
what I think you miss out.
I think if you decide to simplify it,
because you don't want to face that,
so you don't want to face the infinity
that's out there in front of us and you
don't want to face those
stories as you said, that,
that you look at your finger and it's
ingredients cooked in multiple styles over
billions of years.
That that's said to me,
it a joyous and powerful
thing to think about,
and I think you're missing out
if you don't want to face that.